- [Instructor] Let's now tackle part C
which tells us, for T is less than 10,
an alternate model for
the internal temperature
of the potato at time T minutes
is the function G that satisfies
the differential equation.
The derivative of G with respect to T
is equal to the negative of
G minus 27 to the two third power.
Where G of T is measured
in degrees Celsius
and G of zero is equal to 91.
Find an expression for G of T.
Based on this model, what
is the internal temperature
of the potato at time T is equal to three?
So they gave us a differential equation.
They want us to find an
expression for G of T,
so essentially find a solution
to this differential equation.
And then they want us to
use that solution to find
the internal temperature
time T equals three.
So, the first thing to appreciate,
this is in an AP calculus class.
And so they're asking us
to solve a differential
equation, or find a solution
to a differential equation
it is unlikely to be a really
strange differential equation.
It's likely to be a separable
differential equation.
And then once we find that solution
we just have to evaluate
it at time T equals three.
So let's rewrite the
differential equation.
And then, let's try to evaluate.
Let's see if we can find the solution
and then we'll evaluate.
The derivative of G
with respect to T
is equal to the negative of G minus 27
to the two thirds power.
So,
if this is going to be a
separable differential equation
I want to separate the DG
and the DT.
So I'm gonna treat my
differential like numbers
so, or variables.
So I'm gonna multiply both sides
times the T differential.
And so then I'm going to have
the capital G differential
DG is equal to
negative times
G minus 27
to the two thirds power DT.
And the whole notion
here, I'm trying to get
all of the G things
on the side with the DG.
And then all of the things that involve T
in the side with the DT.
So we don't see any Ts here
so really, we just have to get the Gs
over on this side while
leaving the DT there.
And then we can integrate both sides.
So let's see.
If we were to
divide
both sides
by
G
minus 27 to the two thirds.
G minus 27
to the two thirds.
to the two thirds,
what do we have?
Well, we could rewrite the left side as
G minus 27
to the negative two thirds
negative two thirds
DG is equal to
I'm left with just this negative DT.
Is equal to
negative DT.
Now let's see.
Now, we can, or actually just a simplify
or just to make it a
little bit more obvious
I could write this as negative one DT
And now we just have to
integrate both sides.
So, we could rewrite this as
let me write it on both sides.
I'm going to integrate
I'm going to integrate both sides here.
And so what does this give me?
Well, on the left side here
you could try to do some
U substitutions saying,
U is equal to G minus 27.
And then DU would be DG.
Or, you might recognize that look,
the derivative of G minus 27
is just DG.
The derivative of G minus 27 is
just going to be equal to one.
So you could even say, look, I have my
I have the derivative there.
So I could really integrate
with respect to G minus 27.
And so really, I would just
use the reverse power rule.
I would take my G minus 27.
I would increment this exponent by one.
So let's see, negative two thirds plus one
is positive one third.
So positive one third power.
And then I would divide
by this new exponent.
So dividing by one third
is the same thing as
multiplying by three.
So that's the left hand side.
This is going to be equal to
the right hand side.
This is just going to be negative T.
And for good measure
I'm going to have A plus C.
So, how could we solve for C?
Well they give us some
information, they say G of zero
is equal to 91.
So lets write that down.
So, when T is zero
G is 91.
So we can write
let me write it over here.
So three times
so when T is zero G is 91.
Ninety one minus 27
to the one third power
is equal to negative T.
Well now we're saying T is zero.
So you can write negative zero there.
Or we could just not write it.
And then plus C.
So that's what C is going to be equal to.
Let's see, 91 minus 27 is 64.
Sixty four to the one third power
is positive four.
And so we have C is equal to 12.
C is equal to 12.
And let's see, we want to
write an expression for G of T.
So now let's just manipulate
this and solve for G.
So, if we
let me just take this
and go right over here.
So if we divide both sides by three
we are going to get
G minus 27
to the one third power is equal to
negative T over three
plus four.
I just divided both sides by three.
And I can take the cube of both sides
and I would get G minus 27
is equal to
negative T over three
plus four
to the third power.
And I would just have
to add 27 to both sides.
And I'll make it clear,
G is a function of T
is equal to negative T
over three plus four.
All of that to the third power.
Plus 27.
So I did the first part.
This is, what do we got cross
this right over here
is an expression for G of T.
It was indeed a separable
differential equation.
It took a little bit of
algebraic manipulation to get us there.
But we were able to do it
and we were not only able to solve
for the general solution.
We were able to find
the particular solution
using this initial condition right here
the G of zero is equal to 91.
Now, we'll do the easy part.
Based on this model, what
is the internal temperature
of the potato at time T equals three?
So G of three
is equal to negative three
over three plus, I'll just write it out.
Negative three over three plus four
to the third power plus 27.
Well this is negative one.
So negative one plus four is three.
So this is three to the
third power which is 27.
Plus 27 is equal to 54
degrees Celsius.
And, we are done.